l english teacher of human understanding
accendere sottotitoli le stesse su pro
2001 ed allora suite b dove sei rimasti
ragazzi perché l'ultima volta vi ho
capito che c'è e abbiamo capito che non
ho capito che credo di essere in una
specie di laboratorio dove tentano in
qualche modo di farvi scoprire quanti i
neuroni o poi scopriranno un giorno che
né uno solo che balla la samba però
porco demonio che tutto sto casino
ancora non ho capito st questione delle
proporzioni ancora non l'ho capita
affidatevi ok
ce l'ho fatta via al cubo portato in
giro perché sarò un casino
c'è un altro
ok va bene posso 18 va bene ok
fatemi capire a ok va bene o pato sono
passato di sotto non so dove stiamo
andando
ma cosa ragazzi non la sapevo se sono
fatte più di cinque sogni e siete adulti
non c'avete nel culo
buono a sapersi non sognate più di tanto
perché poi un casino raga
piuttosto non dormite basta vi prego vi
giuro non ho più il cervello mi viene da
vomitare giocherò io vi giuro non lo
capisco non lo capisco quando succede un
po come a friends on
se ci pensate cioè sempre tutto bello e
poi cosa arrivi ii f
e poi la metafora della vita sergio va
beh
scusami what
sono le piattaforme di tool da una
all'altra poi spiegatemi sta cosa che
non ho capito cos'è che serve devo
saltare da una catena ci arriverà mai
come arrivo a quella lì spiega mi hanno
forse dovevo fare semplicemente così
ricordo tutto piatto questo vado avanti
era molto più semplice del previsto
effettivamente ok beni che ultimamente
ha oggi mi va di risolvere il quiz non
so come mai non ho capito quello che hai
detto ma proseguo ormai tanto sono
esperto ha quindi vedete sacro santo
iddio vedete si tratta di un sogno alla
fine c'è ora giorgia ciao ragione ha
spiegato lei solo che effettivamente non
è non è mai chiaro quello che sta
succedendo però fu demonio no no no ho
sbagliato è vero che non cedano la
caduta che ha vacca basta st sveglia
basta luca è incredibile come sta parte
ci sarà uscito a farla molto velocemente
rispetto al mio solido ed in genere non
sono così sveglio
negli altri video ci mettono molto di
più a farle con di dover trovare il
generatore per accendere la corrente
come se fosse compito mio non è neanche
piasta facility assassino assassino
assassino assassino assassino assassino
horsey anobit fagioli non capisco lo
vedo niente fuori dalla porta quindi non
posso fare niente
allora pensa fuori dagli schemi loro
forio gli schemi ma così è goku fuori
dagli schemi fuori dagli schemi a esatto
fuori dagli schemi giorno notte fuorché
delle piante
scusate diet soda eccolo inizia a
diventare tetro sto gioco va bene è
diventato wire lips orco demonio vabbè
andiamo a
a non devo cadere di sotto e mi sono
buttato
ma vedi che c'è un'altra via qua c'era
un'altra via
ed io che ne so devo seguire seguiamo le
tracce di sangue ragazzi di è stato un
horror mason live al mazzetto su e spero
che sia il sangue tuo ti ammazzo non mi
fai paura non mi fai paura ho giocato a
tanti di quegli horror che non lo sai
neanche thouar non lo sa nessuno quanti
loro giocato nella mia vita quindi basta
pensare aver battuto il kin e sul record
quello che ha giocato più horror nella
storia qui non mi fai paura smettila che
so non ho ben capito
ecco perché tutto un fake come faccio
nomi non riesco a vedere non capisco c'è
una scala addirittura non vedo niente
potevate mettere due luci in più brutti
pezzenti sovraccarico mentale esplosivo
ma guarda per tutto quello che ho
passato nella mia vita figura lo vedo da
qua porca vacca ho visto la cosa devo
fare
non l'avevo proprio vista quella roba lì
let's go climbing
meno male meno male che sono salito su
quei cosi non ho idea sto capendo
continuamente tracce di sangue sono
finte le tracce non è sangue cioè il
simbolo dell'ikea lo vedo il idea è
tutto chiaro ma ragazzi siamo all'ikea
ma mi chiama dirlo subito ecco perché
non riusciva a trovare la strada di casa
era per quello alla fine siamo all'ikea
mi chiama dillo spiegato se si sta
accendendo tutto vero bravo h
tutto sto casino che questo perché sarà
lì che ha bello però next ei suoi
avvocati bova bene grazie a prezzo o my
god
però io ho fatto in un tempo record
tutto sto casino dove devo andare
cosa sta su un'altra cosa
aiuto una porta a lisbona altre sempre
di piccole vado a farli incontrare a noi
c'è una impossibile veramente tanto non
c'è nessuna lo so che è una presa per il
culo so che mi sia preso per il culo è
una vecchia chiesa lai smettila non ho
capito ma credo di dover fare questa
cosa che sta effettivamente facendo
cercate di doverne impilare di più
insieme
e poi di salire lì anzi sicuro va bene
non fate domande su quello che è appena
successo perché non saprei spiegarvi
costando un quantitativo infinito di
mele non so per quale motivo per
spararle di là dove non è che devo
notare questo affare
non devo notare questa cosa dire quassù
immagino cosa diavolo devo fare la mia
vita spiega mi no beh continuo a
sfondare ma non le posso dare è mi sta
distraendo cioè fantastico se continua a
scavare ea un certo punto il tipo quale
le spinge e quindi non posso fregarlo
fare così sì ma il play che diventano
sempre più piccole dove stai vicino per
sé non riesce a salire porco demonio
ah ok c'è ancora posto per ripristinare
va bene quindi
io lega ce l'ho fatta trovata dopo solo
chi care velocissimo credo che si
passerà la soluzione in realtà non ne
sono completamente con merito a una
velocità di click sul mouse
non sto capendo quello che mi sta
dicendo ma chi se ne frega no ci sono
all'olio l'entrata e togliti ok ho
dovuto ripristinare tutto perché non ci
passavo dove stiamo arrivando in tutto
questo c'è un vaso cantini segna fi che
nei momenti sto capendo la smettiamo di
parlare di dottor pierce che mi dà
fastidio
possa dio siamo arrivate l'ascensore del
messaggio pubblicitario di stavolta farm
to mind mind to bike spera sempre di
cibo ovunque in qualsiasi modo
va bene se aprire questa porta sezione
relax room
oddio mi sembra outlast ragazzi ci
entrava nel prossimo episodio spero che
vi sia piaciuto iscritti anche alessia
cela campanellina e rimanete agiati sui
video e noi ragazzi come sempre ci
vediamo alle possiamo belle ragazze
[Musica]